he has no representation right now so i
don't know who's giving him advice i
don't know who's telling him maybe you
shouldn't practice maybe you should
regardless he is is this a sign they're
moving toward getting a deal done maybe
it is maybe it isn't the bottom line is
he's back at practice and that's good
news for cardinals fans who want to get
the most out of the andre hopkins in his
first year with the team yeah i mean no
doubt i mean this is a huge trade a huge
move for the arizona cardinals football
team a huge year for cliff kingsbury and
kyler murray so you know they they want
their best team out there ready to go
i mean to me it's one of those things
right now that looks like at least the
situation was addressed over the last
few days i don't know who deandre
hopkins you know is gonna go with as an
agent or anything like that you know as
you know i think he's going it alone he
might be he's i think he's doing what
laramie tunsil did right there's a
couple of guys laramie tunzel used to
advise him and that's kind of the new
thing that guys do when they represent
themselves they want to pay somebody by
the hour they don't want to give
somebody a piece of the mission right so
they find somebody out there who will
advise them and there was a suggestion
that he's using the same guys tunzel did
so so i think he's i think he's not
going to hire somebody i think that he's
just going forward like this well yeah
you know first off he's a smart guy he
knows you know the league he's been
around not to say that i ever recommend
as we've talked about any player
representing themselves in a contract
situation because i think that is a
little dicey but regardless i think his
point got across here and whatever his
approach was that
you know the the you wrote about it
other media outlets are talking about it
so
it's on the arizona cardinals you know
radar once again to go wait wait okay
okay we don't want to disgruntle this
guy you know maybe it was one of those
things they swept under the rug just
figuring hey we'll figure it out here
sometime soon and deandre hopkins was
like no we need to figure it out here
you know real soon i'm not going to like
wait until the middle of the season or
something like that so
you know
i would be shocked mike would be
absolutely shocked if we don't hear some
sort of long-term deal for deandre
hopkins sometime here in the next three
four weeks
yeah look he he made the wheel squeak
yeah and simple right and the cardinals
had plenty of other things they're
focused on and it's very easy to forget
about that one thing that's going to
cost you a lot of money and if the guy
isn't clamoring for it well we'll just
keep moving forward and we won't worry
about it until we have to well he made
that squeaking wheel and now
something you're right yeah i i think
something's going on right because it's
not like there was some overwhelming
avalanche of media criticism of deandre
hopkins saying how dare you how dare you
hold in if anything the attitude was
yeah would you expect what he's doing
right yeah and and when you trade for
the guy because he wants julio jones
money plus
when you know that that that's why the
texans are letting him go you bring him
in
you better understand that you're gonna
have to give this guy a new contract at
some point ideally before week one but
most of these guys want to get the deals
in place before they put themselves in
harm's way in training camp period
so he's at 16 4. i think 16 4 or 16 2
we've got the graphic julio jones is at
22. i mean it's a big jump to get all
the way up there 16-2 deandre hopkins is
tied with brandon cooks adam thielen
he's better than both of those guys by
far frankly all due respect to cooks and
feelings
they agree they know they know they're
not deandre hopkins uh julio jones up at
the top at 22 amari cooper at 20.
deandre hopkins is significantly better
than mary cooper at 20. now cooper got
to the market and the cowboys signed him
while he was on the market but it's a
big jump but again
the cardinals had to know when they saw
when they traded for deandre hopkins
that they're going to have to do it at
some point it looks like they have to do
at some point soon yeah they're gonna
and and you know i mean arguably already
you know he's in the these are the kind
of guys you don't want to piss off in an
organization and especially when they
first been traded there and you know
they don't know everybody yet you just
you'd want to set the right tone and you
know of course we know the cardinals are
playing through their offense that's
what they're going to do you hope their
defense is better and good and all those
type of things but we know this is a
team that wants to get in the shotgun
spread it out throw the football and de
andre hopkins you could argue is the
best player on their football team even
though he hasn't played a snap for them
yet so you know you know i and i
understand kyler murray and chandler
jones are awesome i'm not trying to
disrespect them but you know what i'm
trying to say here so uh i i would just
think he is such a big part you know all
the assets they traded to get him and
then he's just a big part of their
future and framing the organization and
kyla murray's career and everything like
that and they're gonna play through the
spread pass game and all that um yeah
they're playing with fire if they don't
get something done real real soon
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports